well thank you very much we got on stage
now we've got the very wonderful anorak
patch who are andrew there's our
wonderful sound check there he's going
to turn them all on possibly we all
we're all alone
would you like to introduce yourselves
say what your name is and what you play
please um i'm effie and i play synth and
sing i'm eleanor and i play bass i'm
luke i play drums
and i'm oscar and i play the guitar okay
okay android patch our local band and
you were having quite a lot of success
nationally and i think what would be
good is if you could talk about how you
got from
not being in a band and not you know and
presumably not writing songs and not
doing anything to be where you are now
because i think that's i think that's
always the most difficult it's the
question that i know we get jane and i
get asked the most is what do i do how
do i get a start what how do i get
started because it's really easy to talk
theoretically about oh you know we do
this and learn this and then get a job
but you know to have it practical
experience how you actually do it so
can i say how did what was your first
gig
um we played in the album which is a
public on my road and we just did a set
of covers
and we played one original song
but it was quite like packed out we were
all a bit nervous that was our first gig
and then
first gig of like original songs was at
the brew house in colchester
another pub but it was slightly bigger
because
we like people saw us at the first gig
and they asked us to play at the second
one so it's just like getting
recognition from like different people
i think there's nothing better in terms
of having long real success than people
coming to see you and hear your music
and liking it and then coming back again
that's kind of it's really it's great
because it's really tangible isn't it
it's real so how did you first start how
did you get to how did you decide that
you wanted to form anorex patch were you
in other bands first or did you play
were you kind of did you have musical
training
who had musical training uh me and luca
did you
yeah
did it hold you back
well we were just friends and then we
thought well we all you know do some
song music that's make it together right
and that's like the key if you're
friends with people who make music then
okay
i've only been playing bass for two
two months or something so i wasn't very
good but obviously being in a band like
helped yeah and then like we're all
friends so it's easy to talk to each
other about like
the issues with the music and stuff and
that's how you progress better okay and
i think that's really i think that's
really important i mean i love bands i
was in a band still and still have for a
long time and it was kind of it was that
gang thing that you're a group of mates
and you do stuff together and being in a
band is kind of one of them and i love
that kind of that feeling that you have
and also that and i think the band well
i don't know how you feel well do you
think you're
together you're better than the sum of
your parts
do you think there's something about i
don't know who writes the songs
um
me and luca i think well
okay
but do you find that they come together
if you're all four of you are working
together do you
yeah
they're improved yeah okay so you you
got together you were what rehearsing at
someone's garage or at home or um in a
natural practice
place oh really
and how long and how long ago so what
was the timeline then how long did it
take you from from first
from you from getting together and how
did you get your first gig um
my dad puts on like
well he used to before kobe put on like
a little festival thing at the pub in
our village okay and so he asked us to
play there but it was like
i feel like our first practice was
december 2018 or january 2019
i think yes and then we played in like
the first weekend of may
right
and then you played the second one soon
after because the other pub was like a
month later okay all right and when did
and when did it start to sort of pick up
for me what happened at that point did
did it start to get
mostly like when covert happened because
people were looking for new music so
they like found us i suppose and then um
we got a bit of recognition
from like some of our newer releases
so you released how much stuff how much
material did you release then uh like
five singles we released like our
biggest song six week party
like
like as soon as uh the first lockdown
happened
and then that got recognized by six
music and we were on the six music
playlist
but yeah that was kind of what did it
right so that was you that was do you
think that was a lucky break they just
picked they just picked up on the track
did they yeah
okay well so you do need a bit of do you
think you need a but you do need a bit
of a bit of luck do you think did you
get that kind of yeah and it's also like
who you know as well like my dad has
been in bands for years right it kind of
helped us get
get gigs in colchester first and then
just play more
and then more people will know about you
yeah also if you're just like friendly
like people if you speak to people then
you've got a connection and then they've
got connections and you build up and up
and up yeah
i think it's important to be kind of to
have a reputation as well as being oh
that you know not only is their music
nice but they're a nice lot you can have
them along and there there won't be any
you know it'll be no grief and it'll be
like they'll come and do a good show and
you know that and i think those
reputations stick you know they'll stick
with you throughout it so okay what have
you how what have you been doing
recently then what
have you been playing we've just been
playing
on saturday was it we played in brixton
uh in london so that was nice where did
you play that windmill oh i know the
windmill okay oh very good and we we
released a single yesterday right what's
that called uh delilah yeah everybody
i've said the obvious one why
why
sorry that's a very joke about a very
old song i apologize i apologize for it
and that's available on all on all
platforms
stream it
check it out okay
and
well what's the plan for the future uh
where are you going tonight like
obviously back home um
where are you where are you playing
after this
um the art center in colchester
in like a month i don't think we have
anything
between now and then we've got one in
london that's the day after that yeah we
have nothing until the 20th of november
okay available here so you're available
for book and how you're presuming you're
all in still in full-time education
as they say yeah how does that work how
do you manage to juggle the band and
education
yeah we sort of like practice in the
evenings right and then the weekends are
when we do all of our shows mostly yeah
and
fair enough okay
all right and did so i was going to ask
about do you have a record label is do
you release your stuff do you
self-relieve but you haven't you have a
label now so yeah okay um nice swan
records right how do you do physical
release as well as as well as online yes
just released our first final your first
one oh okay all right and it's it's
available
is it available might be sold out
actually not sold out
just check for a camera it's not sold
out
okay but it's getting that way okay i'm
very impressed
okay um well i thank you very much for
giving us a bit of a guide
you